Một mọi nhất từ tiêu thương, Giang Yerra Hiem xa Phà Vi, có văn quân sự của đại giáo chủ,
ál y khảm ảy cho thấy, Yván tý tục ra tăng năng là quân sự, nhằm đối phó,
với các mùa đe dọa hiện hữu từ bên ngoài, đặc biệt là từ Isra Rên.
Theo ông Rá Hiem xa Phà Vi, Té Hrer Rán đã sản xuất tháng nghiên tên lua và ua V,
đồng thời bố chí chúng tại tất cả vị trí chến lượng,
nè bảo đam khả năng phần nhàng trong mọi tình hũn.
Dì bên này, giễn ra chỉ vai tôn, sau khu đối đau quân sự,
khăn thẳng dưới Văn Bảy Seren, đưa xem là lần đủ tiên Isra Rên
vượt quan lần dân đò khi tấn công và cơ sửa hàng nhân Yván,
trong quân cô chứng dịch sự tự chối dậy.
Đặc lại Yván phát động chứng dịch lời hữu ở trên thật bà,
bởi hàng loa tý lượng tâm xa, kéo theo các đồng thái quân sự tự phía miếp.
Dù lần bán nơi được thiết lập từ ngày 20 tháng 6,
ta bên đều dưới chi trạng thái tạnh giác cao đồ.
Vyện Yván tôn khai xúc mạnh tình luật,
là tý nhiệm só sang cho thấy nước này sáng sản đối đau,
nếu xung đột cao diễn, đồng thời gửi đi thông diệp xanh đẹp mạnh tính chính lợp,
trong quân cạnh khu vực văn tiêm 1 nhiều bà đồn.